pues no ha defendido desde el principio
que la opción de quedarse en alemania
nunca estuvo sobre la mesa que rusia su
país que echa de menos moscú y que
utiliza seguir luchando contra el
régimen de vladimir putin denunciando
los casos de corrupción y los abusos del
poder pero aquí tiene una condena
pendiente por un caso porque fue
condenado en el año 2014 y lo que
defienden los servicios penitenciarios
rusos es que naval no se ha presentado
para los chequeos habituales
especialmente después de su
envenenamiento los servicios periciales
rusos de que son conscientes de que
desde el 22 de agosto naval ya ha estado
recuperándose en el hospital las arietes
en berlín pero critican que no ha hecho
ninguna comunicación formal sobre su
residencia oficial en alemania al menos
hasta el mes de noviembre aleccionaba le
está aquí condenado por un caso de
corrupción que él pudo cumplir mediante
lo que en rusia se llama a la prisión
suspendido una especie de régimen
abierto o prisión condicional pero
o libertad condicional pero en el cambio
en el caso de su hermano él si tuvo que
entrar en prisión y ahora aunque desde
su plataforma están preparando una
amplia campaña de discursos y mítines la
aleccionaban y se expone una vez más a
volver a la cárcel en rusia